una crisis que tardará en ser superada
la falta de combustible en reinounido
atribuida a los efectos del break city y
la pandemia de kobe 19 obligó al
gobierno a llamar a 200 militares para
que ayuden a transportar el carburante a
diferentes estaciones de servicio
creo que es muy importante que podamos
llamar a los militares en un momento
como éste para ese apoyo extra que
brinde confianza y tenerlo como una
medida posible como una precaución
porque como digo la situación se está
estabilizando nadie va a fingir que ha
vuelto completamente a la normalidad
desearía que así fuera
pero creo que tener al ejército
disponible es algo muy sensato en lo que
hay que pensar
londres insiste en que la situación está
mejorando
sin embargo gremios independientes y
conductores aseguran que podría empeorar
en los próximos días
lo cubren que vaya guau el problema en
reino unido es que nadie más tiene estos
problemas a causa del break si las
fronteras los puestos de control la
salud la seguridad es una pérdida de
tiempo en las fronteras
escenas caóticas en varias estaciones de
servicios se vieron esta semana en
londres donde hubo largas filas de gente
esperando llenar los tanques de sus
vehículos el break city la pandemia se
combinaron este año para dejar también
una profunda escasez de mano de obra en
la economía británica se ha anunciado
que miles de cerdos tendrán que ser
sacrificados ya que no hay personal que
procese la carne también hay una falta
de trabajadores en el sector de la
hostelería y muchas tiendas de menos
recibir suficientes suministros antes de
navidad' miles de visas han sido
emitidas para mano de obra extranjera
pero hasta ahora parece no ser
suficiente